[Music]
all right guys
can you imagine just imagine
okay having this man be
your kindergarten teacher oh i know
you're talking about izzy
as a kindergartner i can't what is it
what if you don't know what's scary
what does he look like jerry is we're
close i don't have photos of that right
now i think it's beautiful
and cool i don't good for him but as a
kindergarten
no it's the his eyes are permanently
black
i think if i was a kindergarten kid i
would accept them more
than now yeah i judge them now and i'm
like get out of here
yeah criminal no the kid you don't know
you you just don't know [ __ ]
because we grew up with that kukui and
that right there is
done yeah no i would have yeah i would
have been freaked out as well as a
little kid yeah
yeah so this man [ __ ] as kids
oh yeah the jazz kids [ __ ] ass kids i
was exploring the world man
that my teacher looks like a lizard
that's what i would say uh so this man
he's
a 35 year old kindergarten teacher
from france and so he goes by the name
freaky hoodie
on social media oh freaky hoodie that's
french
i imagine he comes with little baguettes
for the children every morning
yeah so he says that for the past eight
years he's been
kicking off this hobby of his um since
the age of 27
and at that time he was teaching at a
private school in london
and that's when he says he had an
existential crisis
and so what does that mean tattoos
became his passion
what's an existential crisis i think
when everything around you i think i
think it's when like
you think the whole world is like
collapsing
no it's not even that deep like a
midlife crisis existential crisis is
almost on some like
what's the point it's like it's like who
am i like what am i doing
he's like i'm not myself now i'm myself
with these tattoos
right right yeah deep so according to
the definition
i don't think the world's gonna all
right it's uh existential crisises are
moments when individuals question
whether their lives have meaning purpose
or value and are negatively impacted by
the contemplation oh too much thinking
yeah it may be commonly but not
necessarily tied to depression or
inevitably
negative speculation on purpose in life
see i like i like tim's explanation
we should have a tensionery it's like
we just asked him tim what is what does
this mean but i wish it was wrong
because then i would like it more no i
only i like i like the whole concept of
existentialism just because like i i
like
thinking about you know what what is
what is life and what am i
in this in the scale of life right you
want to get
the meaning of life is that what ex
existential is it's yeah it's almost how
do you say it existentially
existentialism like my existence yeah
it's about like your existence and like
what
like what is the point of it and it's
like that whole thought you want to get
really
[ __ ] up no can i do you want to get
really confident let's do it
[Laughter]
really
[Music]
[Laughter]
no more ah okay i'll tell you joe cover
your [ __ ] ears
uh if you want to get really [ __ ] up
joe then all you have to do is look at
[ __ ] with like outer space and the
galaxies and stuff and then you realize
that there's like [ __ ]
hundreds and thousands of different
galaxies and we're just like this tiny
little speck of nothing
yeah bro that [ __ ] [ __ ] me up no it's
what [ __ ] me up is seeing
that and then comparing it to actual
cells
and like atoms and then like the quantum
physics
the whole universe in one like yeah just
being one little atom
yeah i like to get high and compare the
two
yeah yeah and i go um i feel smarter
because i feel like i understand it
yeah yeah but it's just
colors but then really you know nothing
bro we know nothing
but why do you have to know everything
we don't and it's fine
it's okay i know a lot because i make it
up in my mind
i think that's the meaning of being
human you just create a story for
everything
and then find find your own happiness in
your own life that's all that really
matters
that's all it is baby baby going back to
this dude here so he
he continued his his teaching job right
and so he was saying that
uh he was teaching his students that
you know they maybe hopefully when
they're adults they could be a little
bit more
open-minded less racist less homophobic
and more accepting of others especially
when they look different
and so he like everyone in his class
they always loved him he always had a
relationship with the parents
and no one ever had issues with his look
but then
one day he he unfortunately
inadvertently frightened a a
kindergartener
duh a student who wasn't a pupil oh [ __ ]
um because that's what i was
what i was picturing was him going like
look me in my eyes
like that i'm like teacher i can't your
eyes are too crazy
oh yeah i have i have one of those
photos here
whoa that is [ __ ] scary yeah exactly
how kim know where it's pay attention to
me
and he's got blue cherry blossoms on his
forehead dude
[ __ ] yeah his look is so cool that's
some pens labyrinth
how do you get his eyes so black they
dyed it
i love how it just doesn't go with the
branding right like
you picture this guy to be a tattoo
artist or work at a bar
or something like that he's a
kindergarten teacher but he wants
he's reading a book like this
with a [ __ ] like button-up shirt all
the way up probably doesn't even drink
and
yeah i know right so then he was saying
that you know all of his students are
cool but then after having this
one incident he actually lost his job
oh just because he's scared he's scared
one i don't believe it's from the one
you know it's probably because he was
late every every friday or something
or maybe all the teachers were looking
for an excuse yes we don't like him
yeah whoa they said a couple of months
after
after the complaint was made that's when
when the school
ended up telling him that he will no
longer be teaching kindergarten children
but he is
teaching kids age six and up so
it's not the same first grade kids but
but yeah
and that's that's cool yeah he says that
that decision that the school took
was quite sad um but
you know at least he's still teaching
and he loves his job i like kids too
i like kids they're pretty funny
don't want to take care of them but i
like playing with them dude the other
day
um bart's dad came over and the first
thing type that told him was like
he goes grandpa you're fat he's just
touching his stomach
you're fat i'm like oh i was trying to
tell my dad to like
i was like you know hey dad why don't
you like you know you should work out a
little bit blah blah lose a little
weight
he's like hey who likes a skinny grandpa
grandpa's are supposed to have this
belly oh that's fair
that's a good point leave them alone how
are they with
your your baby coming dude they're so
hyped they're so
excited they're so excited they don't
even give a [ __ ] about me anymore
they're like what does the baby want
what does chia want they do not care
they even wanted me to have they even
wanted me to get she pregnant like even
like
i feel like as soon as they knew that me
and she were kind of serious they were
like just
get pregnant don't even get married
and i'll be like dad no i got i want to
travel i want to do like
go do it just get leave us the baby
we'll take care of it i'll have some
time we're gonna be great grandparents
yeah i could find some babies and leave
it at your parents house
yeah they'd be happy about that who's
babies i don't know
uh there's some kids that need loving
i'll find them you're gonna search and
i'll leave them there
yeah they're just they're just excited
to have some a little offspring you know
because they thought we were uh they
thought we were gonna put it off like
another few years
because we were kind of leaving them to
believe that what made you feel like you
got to bust nuts
you know what we we kind of have been
talking
like we got married two years ago right
and then we weren't in a rush to have
kids but
uh we were like let's have some time to
get married enjoy our married time and
then
when it got to like this year after we
went on the honeymoon because she didn't
want to be like pregnant on the
honeymoon
because we couldn't go on the honeymoon
right away because of the canadian
immigration [ __ ]
so after we went on the honeymoon we
were like okay if if it happened now no
one would like
be upset at it and then um then like
the quarantine should happen and we were
home and i wasn't going to be traveling
i was like oh that's kind of like a good
time and um and then i was kind of like
all right
this is kind of funny because i don't
really believe this [ __ ] but i do
kind of i was like yo it'd be cool if we
had like a pisces baby cause like i'm a
pisces and
i really i like i like myself so and
then i was like if we started
like uh busting nuts now we could have
like during this time we could have a
pisces baby so we're like yeah let's do
it
planned it out and then um it worked out
and is she a pisces too
no she's a capricorn january early
january though are those compatible
pisces and capricorn
apparently yeah what are the two signs
that you're
like tight with uh i think traditionally
from what i've like read
uh water signs tend to be like pretty
you know go together pretty nicely so
like you know like my dad's a
cancer i'm a pisces like that's
traditionally more like laid-back
is what the signs are like i i've dated
a handful of
scorpio women i don't know if that's i
think that's earth that's not water but
they also kind of i think scorpio is
scorpions no i think that might be yeah
sure google it
i've i'm always kind of drawn to scorpio
women back in the day that's because
you're horny
maybe that's true too yeah uh what does
it say oh this is really
good uh i have no idea just type in
water signs sure if only nikki limo were
here i know
water wind fire
heart i'm an aries what sign like i'm an
airy sign i'm air
air yeah fire aries is fire
and then we're cool water scorpio oh
okay so yeah that makes sense yeah i
guess you are sagittarius
oh that's me we're cool with the leos
we are the fires and then the waters
kill the fires so
so you don't get along with scorpios uh
i don't know i'm just making that up
i don't know i i i really don't know you
know what man
there's so many did you ever do your
your birth chart thingy
to see like how compatible you and chia
are birth chart like in the science
well it's not just the sign it's like on
the exact time and place you were born
the stars looked a certain way
like rising signs i i've looked at my
rising [ __ ] but i don't know i've never
looked up my compatibility with her
because because casey and i did one and
apparently we're like really compatible
oh girl was like that's so
funny wow yeah i was like what the [ __ ]
i got a rising sign in the morning
yeah you know what i'm saying did you
get his joke did you hear i didn't hear
it
he said he said i got a rising sign in
the morning
he's dead
you